elon musk is now worth 167
billion dollars and depending on when
you're watching this video he could very
well be worth
even more despite all the five-star
hotels he could sleep in
the tesla ceo chooses to sleep at his
factories not just now and again
but often that's what he did during his
recent visit to the gigafactory under
construction in berlin
tesla's first vehicle factory in europe
that will start turning out model-wise
this year
where do you sleep tonight in the in the
tonight's in the factory
in the factory well technically a
conference room in the factory but yeah
you sleep in a conference room in the
not finished factory tonight
yeah it gives me a good feel for what's
going on alone or
yeah i assume so
[Music]
it's an invitation kidding aside
he's been doing this for years including
camping on the roof of tesla's battery
factory in the nevada desert
and he showed cbs exactly where he slept
at tesla's manufacturing plant in
fremont california
i sleep on the couch over there last
time this year i actually slept
literally on the floor because the couch
was too narrow when things get really
intense i don't have time to go home and
shower and change so i just sleep here
saving time isn't the only reason he
sleeps at work
it's just his style he explains that he
doesn't want to be one of those ceos in
an ivory tower
far removed from the hardships his
employees face on the front line
he says he wants his pain to be worse
than theirs
there's no question his employees have
had to endure a lot to get tesla to
where it is today
the company delivered nearly half a
million cars in 2020
a stunning achievement considering it
was just a month away from bankruptcy a
few short years ago
as it struggled to mass produce the
model 3. in 2018
tesla planned on producing 5 000 model
3s every week
but only managed about 800 a week in the
first three months of that year
frankly we're going to be in production
hell
welcome welcome
part of the problem was that tesla
relied on too much automation
or too many robots too early and any
issue would cause the entire assembly
line to stop
the human staff was also overworked
exhausted and according to a report in
the guardian
even passing out on the factory floor in
response to this article
musk said he cared deeply about the
health and safety of his employees
and emphasized that tesla's safety
record had improved significantly since
then
but shortly after tesla was hit by
another claim of high injury rates at
the factory
so musk responded with an all staff
email that's been applauded by
leadership experts
he wrote no words can express how much i
care about your safety and well-being
it breaks my heart when someone is
injured building cars and trying their
best to make tesla successful
he went on to say he'd meet with every
injured employee and would go down to
the production line
and perform the same task that they
perform
it's not certain whether he actually met
with every single injured person
but this hands-on approach was clear
evidence that he's willing to put
himself at the very heart of
problem-solving
and sleeping in factories could go a
long way toward inspiring his employees
to make tesla an overwhelming success by
helping the world transition to
sustainable energy
tesla aims to produce 20 million cars a
year by 2030.
that's 40 times what it produced in 2020
only an insane amount of hard work will
get tesla there
musk says at times he's clocked in more
than 120 hours a week
a work ethic that he adopted early on
when he and his brother kimball founded
their first company
zip2 which was like an internet version
of the yellow pages
they only had one computer so the
website ran during the day
while they coded at night they also
slept out the office
because they didn't have an apartment
and luckily they could shower at the
ymca
he doesn't expect his employees to camp
out at work but does expect them to
spend a lot of waking hours there
during that painful production ramp up
of the model 3 staff were working 100
hours a week
that's the equivalent of 14 hours a day
seven days a week
critics say he pushed his workers to the
brink musk said there was no other way
to meet tesla's production targets
the company bounced back and exceeded
its delivery goals in the second half of
2019
tesla is now the most valuable car
company in the world
as the stock price continues to soar
musk's rocket company spacex is also
soaring literally
as it tests out prototypes of the
massive starship system
that plans to send people to the moon
and mars even though his company's
futures look bright
the ceo says it's no time to slow down
he once explained that if someone is
working 50 hours a week
and you're working 100 you'll get twice
as much done in the course of a year and
be that much further ahead
perhaps this mentality is the reason
that on glassdoor reviews
only 65 percent of tesla employees
recommend working there
compared with 85 percent who recommend
apple that doesn't mean people don't
want to be hired at tesla
they just recognize it's a demanding
place to work as musk himself has
admitted there are way easier places to
work
but nobody ever changed the world on 40
hours a week
[Music]
so his couch sleeping will probably
continue though he might find it
somewhat more comfortable now
a youtuber named ben sullins started a
gofundme to get musk a bigger couch
a furniture company caught wind of it
and offered one up for free
the money raised ended up going to
charity so when do you think tesla will
be able to produce 20 million cars a
year do you think it'll happen by 2030
earlier or later
let me know and if you like what you saw
as always give it a like and don't
forget to subscribe to my channel
and thank you very much to my patrons
for your support i'm cindy palm and i'll
see you next time